okay for people who are joining our
livestream this is a design meeting
about some features for machine learning
and morph language and basically we're
doing talking about anomaly detection
and missing imputation so let's start up
what is this p-value thing I mean do we
not have an analog of p-value already in
our statistic system
probably what isn't isn't it a CDF isn't
it related to the CDF yeah how is it
related what what would this return
p-value of normal distribution common
point six what should that return so
that would return as a probability to of
event that is where you could integrate
the right tail but also the left tail so
sometimes I call it double tail p-value
yeah what's the relationship between
that and the CDF so we need do we need
our statistics folk here we could invite
some 136 because I think it's Sascha
that have been very interested in the
distribution when you just learn about
80 days ago okay fine well let's get
them here please
you do that Gosha is on the way
okay what about Sascha I don't think he
is but Gaucher is here okay okay so
first question for you go sure p-value
of a distribution how do you compute
that from the functions that we have
hello so look at the screen and tell me
whether this is what what does this mean
p-value of normal distribution common
point six that would return what it
would return
probability that the actual value would
exceed point six is that correct there's
two of them
there's one sided and double sided I
would say yeah for my purpose I only
consider the mill as many sided as
possible value so the total probability
of actual outside of that region exactly
and the region defined by the PDF of
zero point six you know okay it's kind
of a straight I don't know if it's just
that called the p-value because it seems
like an extension of the distribution
it's used in the hypothesis testing so
that gives you the probability is that
your values are outside of yeah I know
what the definition is I'm trying to
find out whether how we compute it's
right here hypothesis test data sorry
right so it's it it's it can also be the
value of the you know survival function
depends which you know which tale we're
looking at and whether the hypothesis is
one-sided or two-sided okay all right
well so okay let's understand by the way
we've got a bunch of background noise
here
sounds like a seashore and kind of
thinking that's go share and there is a
construction going downstairs no that's
not what it sounds like it sounds like
some so Miss connected miss the wrong
I'm a vacation anyway no matter okay so
maybe you can put yourself on mute when
you're not okay
involved okay alright but but so
[Music]
okay let's go back then to this anomaly
detector function okay so what
I don't understand why why this is not
called anomaly detect what is that
something is already trained your
function and rather than having a
true/false you know Oh actually what was
the p-value because the way it works is
that you compute a p-value from an
example and then it's compared to the
acceptance threshold right okay so the
question that you're asking here is if
the distribution was a normal
distribution what is the p-value
associated with an observation of 0.6
that correction that's what I want the
string property be ready to return yes
no no I understand but this is the
minimal case of that right this is the
case with a bunch of with a fancy I mean
alternatively I could say p-value of
learn distribution of blah blah blah yes
comma yes then an example yes yes yes so
this was a side thing so first I want to
know how we call it in the context of
analytical function and then I thought
oh maybe we should do something like PDF
yes well I think that makes sense but I
don't want to overuse a term no we
should not use it incorrectly so we need
to figure that out from the statistics
side of what the right way to do this is
I never found I never found something
for which evaluate everything I find for
p-value is like uni missional
distribution and you know one tailed a
one side tail double side tail p-value
what we have is for any type of
distributions that's been there so maybe
there's another term is that he sticks
for that I didn't find it though sure
any ideas I mean I saw all the question
of the multivariate distributions is
that you know what's your value you know
in a way you know like how you're moving
along the axis
in the in that in the case of the notion
of being great right yeah so that's the
issue and also that goes together of the
fact of you know how quantiles are you
know defined and and and the issue of
you know what how to think about this
region you know for the for the
quantiles distribution excuse me
how did CDF define from multivariate
distribution it's on there on the it's
it's it's it's a multivariate function
so so you have the probability that you
know you're you know X and so your X is
less and you iceless and it's on the on
the coordinate axis yes so that mean one
could imagine some weird polar CDF for
something right because what you're
saying is what's the what's the integral
of that distribution within some region
right yeah so I guess you can imagine
many of them talked about quantile it's
very early to quantize this p-value
stuff what CDF obviously all right but
in the sense that content do not have
weight what is the quanta what's the
multivariate general sorry sorry sorry
no no I know I was confused okay okay so
look one thing that's coming out of this
is the potential utility just because
p-value is such a famous thing to
compute of supporting that for
univariate distributions just in a form
like this Gosha can you comment on that
the mute i I think that's confusing I
mean that this is I mean we have all the
necessary functions defined for
univariate distributions and the p-value
it's it's it's I really don't I really
don't don't don't understand what you
would like with the p-value on that you
know to understand what it is because
it's connected to the hypothesis testing
so it actually there is some hypothesis
so in here you know that what are you
asking for really I mean are you asking
that you're that you're normally this
with the variable it's greater than 0.6
smaller than 0.6 I mean I just equal
point six I just don't know the question
that I mean that we are from an
addiction is not a perfect is bigger or
smaller or anything of the sort the
property that is rarer so that's going
to be the survival function at this
point because so we're function gives
you the probability that your value is
greater than you know point six how do
we know not X 0.6 expectation of PDF of
X below the PDF of point six that's the
same thing isn't it no no no you just
integrate from point six to minus
infinity how you integrate okay I think
so there's a function one could imagine
having which is something like this
where the second argument is a function
that says you know so for example it
could be greater than 0.6 right we could
imagine I don't think it's read
correctly called p-value but it's some
you know I'm not sure if this is the
right thing either but something like
function expectation all right it's just
a it's just a shorthand way of asking
for something like this but it dovetails
with I think a little bit more
what machine-learning case wants to be
but that's exactly the CDF I mean when
you looked it's not exactly the CDF
because this could be any function I
want right that's the whole point the
greater than is just one example you
could put any function you want there
that is and so this is the same as
saying what's the expectation of that
function applied to X with X being
normal you know X being distributed
according to that that's not what we
need for P value again is an integration
of the origin there are the PDF lower
than the PDF of 0.6 right but that's
what you do if you don't compute
expectation you integrate with respect
to the PDF okay let's let's zoom out for
a second before we get too deeply into
this maybe you could show okay so let's
review what these are doing so we've got
an anomaly detector function
and basically I learned distribution
inside right and then we're going to and
the question is what is it returning in
this case it's returning the probability
that this example that's something this
example or worse if I'm not mistaken yes
yes occur yes okay so I think the name
p-value is wrong here
I mean what you're saying is probability
of a rarer example that's that's the
full name of this
um I mean in my case that's what I meant
by p-value in this case yeah probably of
a rare example yes that is correct
simple as that okay who knows what that
I mean is there a name you know rare or
probability I don't know um I mean what
it is is it's a more extreme example
that's what you want to know right you
know yeah
is it more extreme or is it rarer those
are two different things
it is rarer because there's no we don't
speak about matrix here we don't speak
about an example that is bigger or
smaller we only think in terms of
probability of
okay appearance so it's the integrated
probability of all rarer events yes
okay so anybody we've got multiple other
people on the phone somebody must have a
good idea here integrated probability
for rarer events what should that be
called how do we have examples
yeah let's why don't you guys show an
example I mean or you want to show that
I have some things are just to explain
okay I can just share quickly yep just
so quickly the exactly here I'm going to
get just a 2d data set so we can
visualize what's happening from the
areas that I said so I'm going to take
the sepal length versus the petal length
and here is the scatterplot okay and
rental distribution fine
interpret distribution the contour plot
okay so to learn distribution and in red
that was the data so basically if we
take yeah these data point and let's
imagine that the point is actually on
this control so explain time for a
second sorry
they yeah how does this relate to
estimated distribution what you get here
so I've used estimated distribution for
this as well parametric right what you
do it some parametric estimation so it
kind of looks like one of the data
distributions smooth smooth kernel
distribution or chronometry distribution
probably so you have here the kernel
density estimation x' which are probably
using the standard Gaussian kernels for
that yes okay all right fine information
now we have that okay yeah now what you
want to do is you want to state a sepal
and petal length and you want to say
what's the integrated probability that
you have something for that sepal and
petal length you know it's it's in
somewhere in the ocean there let's let's
say seven three or some things right I
put a point at seven three right what
your question so that will have some
probability density value at seven three
and you're saying integrate all of the
places in this universe that have less
than or equal to that probability
density value exactly so you'd like if
you do I doing the contour plot that
passed by this point and you are
integrating so integrating the PDF of
course
of everything that is outside this okay
so who knows what that should be called
is there anything in the literature for
what that should be called it's James
here does James know sorry
but it is one extension possible of
p-value it's a pretty yes but I think
it's a okay so let's try to capture what
it is that we're talking about here what
so what we're talking about is
integrated rarer probability is that
incorrect statement or so that survival
function range I don't know I mean it's
a survival function I mean I've heard
that used for very different kinds of
things and it keeps you there and I know
but that's like for univariate
distributions isn't it it's it's fine
for multivariate as well but it's that's
integrated what about VF right right
what about the name rarer cdf and the
description well was that crazy
I mean cdf means you I don't know
integrating from you know the travel
metric where you're integrating survival
function it's an inside it's an
integration of the PDF it's just a
different different side right you see
all right that's exactly that you're
you're thinner tail of the PDF you know
like you above certain so so the
question is if you know with if this is
what you're looking at because CDF it's
a community from the PDF right so so you
have you have the values but the the
thing that we that we that I'm trying to
connect because we're talking about
events that's one space probability
space and then we're talking about the
values in PDF that's a different space
that's what we are in the reals or you
know whatever the space numbers
right so I'm trying to connect and so
the thing is that rare events in the
probability space they they correspond
to the events today to the low PDF value
right yep so so this is you are in a
tail what we call the tail of a
distribution right and then the question
whether your events there are events are
you know probable you know or not' then
we have these distributions with what
they're called fat tails and such yeah
yeah right and so so I'm trying to kind
of connect what what you need because if
you just need to integrate you know PDF
on the other side then CDF then we have
survival function this already I
understand but the point about look the
term survival function suggests a time
axis of some kind because that's where
that name came from we simply don't have
that here because we might have you know
these are might be pictures of cats and
dogs and the space might be you know
three hundred dimensional right so I'm
gonna push again integrated rather a
probable let's say okay okay let's write
it down for now to great T the rarer
probability well I found integrated a
bit to mathematical for somebody that
just use a memory detection okay all
right so let's think about that but so
what this is is well we could just say
total rare a paparazzi yeah yeah yeah I
like nicely and simply what you wanna
say actually I it's explicit at least
okay well just wear our probability
and you lose the idea that you're doing
an integral yeah I think you need the
total because I think the whole point
exactly the probability of having a rare
event so coming from distribution okay
so what about rarer event probability
that's I like it a lot and we're over
example better example communicator
machine learning we'll talk about often
about example where that our ability
hmm what about just rare a probability
which is I think what was suggested
before where I think I think that a
nightmare probability I mean in the
context let's see yeah so we're asking
the question example where our
probability it will be using that or we
have to see how it be as well right it's
going to be use degrees I'm gonna take
the function an example
okay so it is the probability for
something rarer to occur yeah I think
total would be helper helpful
the total rarer probability the total
probability for something rarer than
this to occur
you just write that down total
probability for something rarer than
this to occur for something rarer than
example might also consider reward
commodity if you wanna avoid total and
then cumulative goes together with
another side yeah the problem with
cumulative is again it suggests a very
one-dimensional notion I mean cumulative
maybe maybe I don't know I think total
rare probabilities is descent why nots I
was too stupid to toll because when you
speak on everyday when you it's me like
Oh what are the chances that I don't
know that I'm older than 80 years old
yeah you don't say what are the total
chances or what are the total
probabilities that I I know but that's
again a one-dimensional case what what
you're saying is look I think you need
total here's why okay you've got a
distribution of cat pictures right you
showed a picture of an elephant right
it's not the case that there's a
one-dimensional thing that goes from
cats to elephants instead it's the you
know there could be an elephant there
could be a potato there could be a tree
each one of those has a rarer
probability than the than that elephant
and so this is the integrative
probability of all of those rare are
pictures which i think is a you know in
the case where you're in one dimension I
agree with you but we're not we're
dealing with the it's a slightly bizarre
thing I mean it's saying in in this
whole space that's a complicated
multi-dimensional space I prefer this I
think okay I think we've got thing with
wording like what is the probability
that we look to an age above 90 the
above 90 implies a sum whereas in the
case of an image you know the difference
between two images there's no nice
wording that implies the Sun like that
yeah that's right okay doing that looks
good I want to see no I shouldn't
accident
so as though obviously okay I'm here at
some examples may I just add let you
know okay let's take a look at because
what we are talking about here is the
way to handle missing data what is that
yes no it's just a PDA sampling this
will be a sampling so here I'm so
basically this Linda tribution they know
how to do PDF query sample and imputing
missing values well and and you can also
do the mean of that distribution count
you know no in that case you could
because it's numeric but because it's
intended to be arbitrary spaces we
didn't implement me know object just so
I understand other statistical things
that are sort of I mean it requires some
kind of super robust statistics to be
able to work in these weird spaces I
would think is there a notion of a
median if you define PDF and you kind of
can derive the properties so that PDF
right so you have the corresponding
variables so in that sense you can
compute mean for this distribution it
doesn't mean that you gonna have the
mean of the pictures that's that's on a
different space so when we talk about
here you know showing the PDF you see
it's in terms of X Y being numbers right
so for that you can compute no but this
is a particular case where it's
numerical data if it's a cats and dogs
pictures thing the mean of the cats and
dogs my text but that's what's what's
your distribution on the on the owner on
the cats pictures this is not numeric no
I mean the cat could be because we we
for example confirm the images before so
then it's kind of a defined numeric
space if we don't confirm the images and
it would be because all image are
different sizes so the way we are a
space but in the case of texts or things
like that
then the space is not numeric at all and
and so we don't have mean we don't have
me the end we don't have we can just
simple compute I don't know expectations
maybe could you just pull up the page of
statistical computations mean might not
necessarily equal data mode is often a
useful exists we all know that
communists that's what we call
communists yeah right
yeah just published in statistics let's
look at that and let's look at a scroll
down where is it scroll up
I guess random variables go to the
random variable section their
distribution related functions yep these
we have just click on that click to that
we don't so yea PDF we don't have CDF
and why don't we have on this page why
don't we have communists do we have
communists as it has a go show that will
be a question for you that's gonna be
the descriptive measures so descriptive
statistics probably exists for
distributions yeah and it doesn't exist
for distributions why not because
first of all it's not super well-defined
and it requires a unimodal distribution
second there is a choice of what we
support for these functions it's very
expensive to support additional ones now
we did you talk to Eddie and he only
supports one which is PDF there's 35 of
these okay 35 watts of these properties
that you have for distribution where are
those properties if you go back there
moment there's another sub guide page
for moment related things and so on
I'm having a hard time finding stuff
here special moments is not where I
would look for to find the variance of a
distribution we go back to that first
guide page for a second
this is about Providence to
I'm surprised that things like me aren't
here
this is for random variables not fluent
in statistics the descriptive statistics
is you've got one back no that's okay
that's wrong
yeah okay so there you've got so there
we've got mean and variance but where is
the stuff about the descriptive
statistics it's it's it's it's a tone
guide page don't they're related guides
okay I go to related guides it seems
like policies to top first of the
derived guides
write scripts but it seems like I'm just
pointing out but for a mo page that says
probably since statistics one would
think one could get to that more easily
in a point that's a long debate and we
can have that debate okay all right okay
let's not deal with that right now okay
so could we go back I'm sorry go back to
that page again please hmm okay so my
question is which of these are plausibly
supportable for these wild learned
distributions
I think communists
[Music]
for this one I think only communists
know now anything that use a matrix is
by by entropy entropy yep yep yep so
oops that's so these are very data
oriented as opposed to sort of you know
distribution oriented
you
well yes communists what would communist
mean communist means if you've got the
cat picture distribution what does
communist mean it means a communist for
a distribution would mean if it's a
unimodal distribution it's the peak of
it well I understand but I'm saying for
cat pictures we've got a distribution of
cat pictures what is a cat that is most
likely the most likely cat yeah which is
the same thing as the whatever we're
calling it takes a synthesis so what are
we calling that now yes I'm entity a
little designer random data synthesis oh
yes right what some random variate sort
of the none area network yes it's a
random variate affair it's a child and
distribution just learn to produce later
I I don't understand why that isn't
simply random variate of a lone
distribution so for example for cat
pictures what's the difference between
random self-critic yes so yeah we could
have just not had this function and to
just be random variate I guess if we
have this it will let the user give
these intents to only use the
distribution for generating yes all
right fair enough
Turner so that's random synthesis you
give it a big loss of data which could
be weighted data of pictures of cats
including you how favorite your cat the
cats are and it will then generate a
pseudo count so to speak yeah okay what
in the space of cats it is the it's the
winning well if its mode I would
interpret commonest as being querying
the mode so so values it is PDF yeah so
I'll be interested to see what that
actually is for cat pictures is it
something sensible or not well for
example
we understand can you American youth
safe the amnesty data set can you say
immediately what the mode of that is we
don't have something to complete the
road but let's say a train distribution
I can look at a test set the one that
has the highest value but we don't have
a way to it's also not easy because it's
an optimization yeah it's an
optimization process with respect to the
parameters and I mean what this would
presumably do I mean people have done
this with neural nets right is like what
is the best elephant picture or the most
elephant elephant picture if I'm not
mistaken is this useful as my question
to find the the mode of the cat
distribution so to speak I don't think
it's really useful for this case okay in
general I'm a believer that samples are
as good or even better for most
application and mode people like to
maximize though and get the map you know
for example the missing imputation okay
typical case okay that's where we leave
them all actually you have some missing
data you want to include them yes so we
can condition distribution and then a
tooth choice either you get a random
sample from this conditional
distribution they all get promoted it's
typically people like to of the mode in
this case which I'm showing many
application it makes sense I think in
others you'll find writing a sample
there is one really big use case for
having samples which is a mouthful
imputation where you impute multiple
versions of the data set then run your
analysis multiple times and aggregate
the results of those analyses to get a
better idea of sort of variance in your
yeah okay we have it we have a number of
interesting comments on our live stream
here which let's just address for a
minute and then we're going to talk
about missing imputation a
representation of missing data so
somebody's asking about causal inference
and I don't know what do calculus says
they're asking about our plans for
causal inference there TN can you say
something about that there's no plan at
the moment I guess it will come quite
later I think this is not a short-term
thing probably will work on prolific
programming before a critical model
before and then tryna there's some
simplest thing that I don't know about
but it was quite low on my list
Roger do you have comments on that um no
not really
I do think both graphical programming
and probabilistic programs are really
quite important right
okay comment another comment probability
density P R of X has dimensions of 1
over X if you transform X 2 f of X where
f of X the normal function contours do
not correspond to contours of P of X ok
the point being made here is the
definition of rare probability density
is coordinate dependent yes I mean in
other words if you make a coordinate
transformation on your I mean I don't
but is there any useful meaning to that
I mean in the space of cat pictures what
on earth is the coordinate system I mean
the what is the metric in the space of
cat pictures do we have to define that
order we must have to define that yeah
we define it by conforming the images
and then we just take this numeric space
so they all have the same dimension the
images yes and they are basically
you're saying that they are a bag of
pixels basically races conformed space
and then what and then it's basically
any other space so yeah it's so what's
the distance between them small we yeah
I mean depending which descends but
directly and it would be its Euclidean
distance between those those high
dimensional points which means that the
probability I'd its coordinate depend on
what they yes that's why it's not yeah
super well-defined nevertheless in
practice so if I look at the PDF of this
stuff by the way this is most likely out
of the one or the example that I put
this is a PDF of this stuff now if I
take a random image finger fix the
underflow problem yeah so you know this
is enough to say that 10 to the 600 is
bigger than ten to the minus three
hundred thousand you can do look PDF on
that it would be so yeah we do I put
this for my detection that what's
relevant is PDF in the space that the
data are given particularly by changing
the coordinates and suddenly make some
things more anomalous and some things
make less anomalies
yeah well that's obvious I mean it's
obvious that if you transform the even
if you do image transformations you can
clearly change something you know yeah
you can you can change it around so fine
so it's coordinate dependent we should
probably make sure that that's a note in
the documentation someone
complaining there's a root means square
but there isn't a mean squared
do we want to comment on that Roger do
we want to comment on that see it again
we have a function root means square but
we don't have a mean squared function is
that simply because do we have mean
squared operating on distributions so
they know what is mean square is the
square of root mean square I think yeah
well arguably you could just square the
root mean square right okay so you know
the color is what you often want that
because you know in optimization you
don't really want to use that square
root on top there just remove it I don't
know it's a suggestion for having
another descriptive statistics' suppose
to me right so can we
I think Sushma you're peeing here can
you make a note of that yes separate
discussion um someone else is pointing
out most of us together users will
prefer to train again themselves
directly to generate samples comments on
that
examples the train again generative
adversarial network I don't I don't know
I mean we're providing something which
is an easier packaging of this stuff
that's a that's a fairly complicated
thing to do um okay let's go back to
your the missing imputation stuff
am I going to go back to my screen or
you you can you can use your screen here
I can yeah okay okay so what's the
message in huh how to represent missing
data so so far we just use me saying for
example and it didn't dis relate to a
whole annotation discussion yes well did
we didn't finish that discussion but so
I mean I said yes I guess
[Music]
things would feed to a present here is
two numerical vector and missing at
position three missing a position one
okay do we have anybody from much
processing on this meeting Carlo Rovelli
much but I think pewter is also here by
the way this Piazza here yes here
okay great um cutter can we hear you do
you mean oh yes yes really fine okay all
right okay so
all right let's go back to my screen
because I've also got this stuff from
the previous annotation discussion
um okay so the issue is we are trying to
impute so for example what is the name
of thing that fills in scratches it's in
painting right how do you specify where
you want it in paint I see just go
region two in paint so that right so I'm
sorry another image of graphics is
basically a mask that is completely
separate from right I understand so
that's one example in in painting that's
one example of a place where you are
effectively saying this is missing data
that I want to impute am i right
yes and this has to be special I mean
there's to be only black and white
against the mask yes for in paint banana
mask yes and are you saying in the case
of missing imputation that you can have
a non-binary mask
to be binary masks yeah yeah yeah I was
just wondering what you could give I'm
just trying to think in terms of general
expressions because these two images are
not like you could say I mean I don't
think we want that but to say only the
first channel of the pixel five is
missing I say and I'm trying to think in
the arbitrary expression could we
express you know that our given location
you have some missing that's right okay
but as you've said one approach and this
relates to the general annotation thing
one approach is a mask this this I think
let's pull up again
hey Sushma do you remember where I have
the information on the annotation stuff
no I was time I've made that suggestion
that you were there okay so here I've
got my notes okay um okay so right so
this is the
cases where we have markups of various
kinds including for example
um
let's see so here are some of the things
we've talked about the annotation rules
possibility where and value so that's
saying in an image I want to annotate
that this is a picture of a of an
elephant or something right but these
pixels are I want to carry around with
the image the annotation that this bag
of pixels represents an elephant
am I making sense or an audio that this
you know part of the time series
represents the speaker alright and so
that would be an obvious way to carry
around things like missing I mean that's
masking a masking approach to missing
um
okay so you're saying so let's let's
enumerate the cases that we need to
[Music]
um
that let's enumerate the cases that we
need here
right what types of data are we going to
deal with here we're dealing with image
data we are dealing with in general for
now
which includes imagine audio right yes
for 12 we won't have audio for the
distribution okay
basically I have everything that has a
fixed dimension at the moment yeah okay
all right okay
but Sir no series for now no time series
okay all right fine that's not relevant
to this design discussion okay
see I see because you can't I don't even
know how you do that well how do you
deal with the distribution for an
unbounded thing like that you can do
that so it will make mostly you know
return your network type thing that will
so basically we will decompose the
distribution as being you know the
probability of the first element time
the property of a second D given the
first times will give a third given the
history and so on the second chain of
events the distribution and yeah it's
kind of what we do for you know for
language models yeah I understand
okay so it's I see okay so let's come
back to
alright so there are these cases where
it is data dependent where you're saying
this this thing in the data will be
considered will be taken to be what so I
mean in general this will be some kind
of pattern thing right here you say if
the data matches this pattern you want
to impute it okay that's one possibility
yeah I mean here's a question this is me
hacking but yeah well here's a question
why is this called missing imputation
why does it have to be missing why isn't
it data imputation
you
okay I don't think there has to be
missing so if we said data imputation
of the existing data comma and now we've
got to say okay so we're either saying
you know where is the data missing as
the data to be imputed
I mean this is like it's almost like an
interpolation function where you're
given some data and then you're told you
know go figure out well what you're
going to return from this is new data
that's had those pieces added in right
or or replaced basically it will return
missing in pewter nice huge it will
return a new data but the data input
should use a verb it will
I guess the difference between data
imputation and missing data imputation
is that in the case where there is
missing data you don't want to use that
data to learn the distribution whereas
in general data imputation if you want
to replace things you might still want
to use the values in the data set which
aren't missing I don't know if that
means I see a search is saying so in
other words during the learning process
okay so that's that's a that's an
important point
so do we parameterize that right now
amia did you understand really yes
actually we can have the option that we
train like we impute while training or
not impute you know what James is saying
is if there was data there but we just
should be included in training or not
yeah that's right we don't have it right
now but okay fine but but then so what
we're saying is this data we're trying
to divide the data into two bins the
data that we're leaving they said that
were just copying from the original and
data that is to be replaced somehow to
be imputed
is that correct mm-hmm
I mean yes and the idea of having the
name missing imputation was that by
default if you don't give it anything
and if it would be missing in there like
any missing pattern so it would by
default consider those as missing it's
like I understand I think that that's
not actually Sandra our live stream is
asking why we're just calling this
imputation rather than data imputation
and I agree that the word imputation I
don't know impute I'm not sure okay but
let's go back to this question about
we're dividing it into two bins the bin
of things that were just copying over
and the bit of things that want to be
replaced when you mean things
you mean like just some example that any
one bin is some example that in to be
you know other bean because no no no no
I'm saying that in in the space
these examples are living in some space
that cat pictures with you know position
for the nose of the cat or something and
each of them are some missing values yep
okay and then what comes back from
impute I don't understand what comes
back if you have got a collection of
examples and you say data impute to all
the examples come back with the with the
yeah cracks filled in yeah okay so and
but what about if you want to give an
existing distribution like an existing
image distribution and then you won't
just want to impute from the existing
image distribution like like the first
argument would be a distribution that
time shoots the distribution and then I
think that's what we've really designed
and then what then what's the second
argument that's then there will be
examples that are to be a two argument
version of the time feud maybe right so
you're saying that what we've got here
is data impute of distribution comma and
then the data a single piece of data or
multiples of data yeah and that should
return new data that has very similar to
in accept now the third question so the
question is how do we represent what's
data what pieces of data are to be
imputed so what we could do is the third
argument here could be very much like it
is an in paint essentially a region of
data for which to do imputation which
will go beyond the next arguments
because in classify let's say I'm I also
want to give imagine missing data
I don't know is it of course it's less
common than in this imputation okay
but why not to classify you're saying
classify you're saying that the the
thing that is coming in as the thing to
test the picture of the potential
rhinoceros that's part of the thing torn
off they say is this a rhinoceros even
though we tore off I mean this for sure
for sure
we have missing that I mean data sets in
general have a lot of missing values so
you keep on learning from the Italian
values and evaluating your model on the
data and using values that's for sure
but it's read most the time the missing
value happen when you have numerical and
nominal data set so we didn't have a
strong need to give an image reasoning
value it's rare that your data sets and
you naturally have missing values in the
image what I was just saying for the
sake of generality you know way to
present using data you know right but so
what we call curvatures in our proposal
over here is some kind of
for sound oh I'm sorry
yes no no I was saying actually cannot
happen to have imagined anything values
or sound that anything values um it was
a really common to have like tabular
data like say Hospital Records or survey
results which have tons of missing data
this yes so we've got but we've got a
mechanism for that we've got the missing
some grammar the problem is that we it
is inefficient and crazy to have the you
know every every pixel in the crack be a
be a pixel that's encoded with missing
now I think for images we have talked
about having some kind of nan
representation internally for the images
that not correct Piatra can you comment
on that definitely not in 12 we
represent image data and we in America
right now I understand but we're talking
about going forward into the future are
we going to do that and use that as a
lookup table the the presence of an an
is something which forces a lookup of
something more complicated in the image
or are we going to do it differently
well we haven't got to that point you
can accept that discussion what are we
going to do with images there was only
discussion with Marc soprano and
compiler people that at some point we
want to have not a numbers stored in
numeric arrays that's all it was so far
I just make two points one is that using
man as a missing value indicator can be
a bit dangerous because often you might
do some sort of the you know the users
might be some sort of pre-processing or
something which is arithmetic which
generates an an good point the point of
that what I was saying is the nan is not
representing the data the nan is
basically a way to not tangle up the
innards of the system while saying
there's something wrong with this pixel
then you have to go look up in an
external table what's wrong with that
pixel
did that make sense
I think I see what trend is what you're
saying okay anyway your second point the
second point was that if you are worried
about how to efficiently store
information about where they are missing
values rather than using a full-fledged
matrix you could use some sort of sparse
matrix representation because I think in
most cases the amount of missing data
will be much less than the amount of non
missing data I was thinking about that
as well it could be at least a position
and this would work for arbitrary
expression so maybe it's a bit
cumbersome but you know it could be like
missing data then input whatever
expression and then second argument will
put like at least a position where it's
missing well that's the where our what
annotation mechanism here
I mean clearly yeah it is the position
is very clean way of implementing this I
mean that may not be the best well but
it's okay we could support both things I
mean if you if you give it an image it
could figure out that what you mean is
the positions of those pieces
um should every rapper
like missing data data coma and that we
support values way to declare what's
missing and where it's missing sorry say
that again next we have a rapper
where do we think we get images with
missing data
whether where does it happen in real
life in question like so he made it as a
crutch no that's a that's a very obscure
case because that's a I mean where does
it happen it happens it probably doesn't
happen very often I mean things like
dead pixels in a camera a CCD array it's
pretty rare I think I think it's more
for removing something in a picture or
like by hand so this is like you know in
Photoshop or something you can go and
you can just say I want to remove that
you know random temple on on a nose or
something and it will just go and fill
it in with stuff around it yeah all the
person behind me and yes you can also
imagine applications such as repairing
photos that were any damaged in a fire
or things like that yeah alright that's
that's the case we're seeing with the
scratch but but so the case of relevance
the case isn't settling like the
mainline case to me it sounds like in in
that case it's not a mainline case the
case of of getting rid of you know
photoshopping people out of images
that's pretty mainline that's a routine
thing done all the time with things like
Photoshop but then doesn't a name seem a
little audio it's terribly odd yes for
that I mean I can imagine a special
purpose function for the image case that
says there's it's in paint right it is
they already
fair enough fair enough yeah I mean is
this does this become a method for in
paint not emitted for in why not it's
functional learning from some data so I
understand but if the frame
yeah if we've trained something on
generic photographs for example then it
is yes use this foreign paint
definitely so one thing that comes to
mind so let's assume that we have an
annotation system that is well designed
and it networks which is not - at the
moment this data imputation it seems
like it could benefit from that saying
rather than just replacing missing
values like replace the data in this
sensation with whatever exactly yes I
agree he doesn't seem to be depend on
the fact that data is missing yeah it
seems to be the only thing you need to
know is where and
yes where or what because again that's
that that's the point if we've got
annotations then we could we can remove
based on annotation value look okay okay
okay so um I think what is interesting
but it's a little different so that's
like saying the blue blue things it's
like a green screen but but that's that
to me is it's a way of specifying where
kind of like the color neighborhood to
cut you know it's it's a I'm saying it's
it's a way I see it right but okay so
look your basic point is which elements
of the data are to be imputed yes right
by the way is this notebook saved
somewhere should I save this and no it's
not saves any more at the moment I just
quickly didn't send you very late okay I
put it in known that framework um okay
impute based on
oops based on which elements of the data
are to be imputed that's that's the real
question
I mean it's interesting to use the word
impute if we could okay what would
happen if we just used impute similar to
interpolate right so how does this
relate actually we call it interpolation
don't we interpolation
okay so we'd say imputation which will
be like interpolation so interpolation
you give it you know this and it returns
an interpolating function imputation
what will we give it it would return an
imputation function is that right that
in yes it's actually the same well it's
not quite the same because that has a
lot of those things called um a
participle um okay so actually sorry
it's we include our function sorry sorry
okay so whatever whoops um but what is
that that computer function is so you
don't get new data that's something that
you can then apply to your data start
right let's let's walk through what
these actually have so imputation of
data note
distribution and no this will be impute
this will be impute impute can be can
either directly impute or take a
distribution okay but let's look at that
as analogy by analogy with interpolation
okay so imputation there would be
examples you know this a set of examples
or conceivably you could just give it
directly to the distribution I guess it
could work like that as well this rule
so then it will be analogous to
interpolation so imputation
if I say range of 10 I'm trying to
remember how this works if I say 0.7
yeah okay so that's what right so so
then imputation by analogy would be
imputation of the examples comma
[Music]
specific data I don't know what we call
it the thing that we are imputing about
data let's call it um let's call it
input okay and that would return output
data correct it would return the post
imputation version of that input correct
yes we could do that
and then imputation on its own
of examples would return an imputation
yeah
not about the case where you are
learning from the examples which you
wish to impute this would be impute this
will be the verb I don't understand that
guys or women but what it's you learn
from the examples and you impute on the
examples I see that's a very weird verb
for that
I mean it's a self impute I mean it's
made like you know demented reduce data
impute the data and anomalies in the
data
it's a little weird what would you say
if you were making a longer name for
this case you'd missing maybe because
they have to have missing stuff
otherwise there's nothing to do yeah but
these things even in this case it has to
have missing stuff where there's nothing
to do
exactly he isn't about to add missing I
mean it's clear otherwise I mean impute
is obscure and I didn't know what into
it meant I mean I'm not English first
language but until you know two years
ago maybe
yeah I agree it's an obscure word so
missing impute okay it's right to
missing I understand and that sort of
generally accepted plan for it actually
a funny story when I started doing the
machine learning functions I thought it
was an N another M because just to close
the input and so the first processes are
called
input we are right well the weird word
you
oops
you
can you compare with an input let's
compare with interpolate
you
hmm well that's because it's a different
meaning of the word impute it is a
different meaning I think a meaning like
to give responsibility to I know of
course I think it's it's to I mean I
include the fort - yes right
what I meant earlier was that missing
data imputation or I guess missing
imputation is in you know in the machine
learning community people generally know
what that means
yeah I agree well I mean as well right
this argument this is a strong argument
against using the plane would impute not
a single one of its meanings is useful
yeah agreed
um but was me saying it makes it
acceptable I think
so then let's go back to what you
proposing earlier nesting imputation of
data go ahead Roger yes so this is
there's kind of a more global view you
know let's say that I have financial
data and there's missing data would you
dare to use this function you know if
you're gonna bet if you're gonna base
models on the conclusion of your imputed
data you mean because there was a
holiday on a particular day and there
was no price value and you still want to
solve use that as some downed
recondition for a differential equation
or something yeah I mean there's other
calculations that's going to in fact
rely on that data so I mean these are
interpolation
look I mean interpolation is an
alternative to this kind of impute I
mean interpolation is similar to this
imputation I think except that it
doesn't deal with bloodlust took stuff
it's just a saying you know I've got the
single you know thing of data am i right
I mean interpolation is an extremely
junior version of imputation that
doesn't allow probability distributions
it just is looking at the data itself
and trying to fit it difference is a key
difference going back to that financial
data question of would you use this on
financial data what you would do is you
do multiple imputation so you take
advantage of the fact that you have a
probability distribution that you can
solve the problem and use sample sample
multiple versions of your data set and
then run your analysis on each of those
individual versions of the data set and
then you can look at the end and
aggregate the results of those analyses
and say what is the variance in these
analyses and they need to be I bite out
completely that that makes perfect sense
it's a good argument who made that
that's James okay that's a solid
argument um okay let's come back here
okay so is there any alternative to the
term missing imputation I mean it is a
slightly weird word I understand that it
means something in the machine learning
world is there any more common term for
that him well sometimes they're called
missing data handlers or they are
handler is a different thing that's what
you do like if you're computing the mean
or something what do you do to the
missing data right and there are more
specific names for various and you know
things that have developed before this
approach was developed which is also
stochastic so in signal processing for
instance for things like time series and
other things there is it's called a
smoothing problem when you're allowed to
use all the data around you to sort of
you fit the best possible model and then
you use the expected value that's gonna
be in there in between okay but let's
come back to the questions it's like a
generalized common filter you like
missing data yes or missing data
estimate yellow fill in missing data
of course we keep on saying it doesn't
necessarily have to be missing right it
could be taking you just don't want to
use for some reason I mean you might
want to remove the anomalous data right
so in other words you've got a measuring
device and the measuring devices usually
measuring just fine this is different
thing there's like sensor data as well
like yeah so yeah so there's missing
gauge of the sensor data the sensor data
is a different thing yeah you've got a
temperature measuring thing and suddenly
a dragon walks by and breathes on your
on your measuring device and so you
stupid measurement well that's not
censoring but what is that you you you
let's say that here's a concrete example
you do a set of trials like medical
trials and then you want to figure out
if it's changed the sort of death ratio
but by the time you conclude the trial
not everybody has yet died they will
eventually die you just don't know when
yesmy is that you have an open interval
for your data so you have you have some
data but it's like an interval or a
range of possible values instead of a
crisp data point fine outliers named
outlier yeah this comes down to the fact
that there are multiple different types
of missingness so since the data is a
type of missing data and there's a whole
bunch of literature on this you get
missing completely at random data you
get missing at random data and then you
get not missing at random data in
censorship depending on the type of
censorship is either not missing at
random or missing at random as a person
isn't completely at random and with even
completely around what does that mean so
so I'm yeah so missing completely at
random is if the whether or not a value
is missing does not depend on the value
itself or any of the other values that
are related to that value how so
then missing at random is when whether
or not of value is missing doesn't
depend on the value itself but could
depend on other values that are related
to it so in a multivariate analysis
maybe you know one of you remain missing
for an example and that missing list
depends on other dimensions but not this
actual dimension that's missing and then
not missing at random is the case where
the missingness depends on the actual
value that is always impressing and this
is important to consider because
different imputation methods are going
to be suitable for different types of
missingness or not suitable for certain
types
yeah that sounds like a slightly
different meaning of sensor yes
different different meaning I understand
censorship let's say you've got a
measurement of voltage and current and
the sensor breaks in the case when the
voltage is too high and then no longer
reports current when the voltage is too
high or maybe when the voltage is too
high it doesn't report the voltages
clearly so your censoring I think is
there's a sensor with a see this example
uses both words but but James I think
you know it's different if the measure
of brakes then the data is missing
afterward but either measure as a
maximum value the cannot measure more
than 100 degree and which one degree
then you don't know you just know it's
above 100 degree this is right exactly
again right which not really missing and
I think it's we don't need to plant and
so data for us now I want to say about
missing at random in missing in petition
we are going to assume that the fact
that it's missing or not has no
correlation with so to speak with the
value itself all the other values
because I don't know how we could do
otherwise at the moment trying to
mention that ok but ok
there's no dependency model is what
you're saying
yeah I mean the values are dependent all
together of course but the fact that
it's missing doesn't depend on the
values okay let's say it's missing its
was probably higher or something like
that we need to represent you know
quotes missing whatever that means
or a ka ignored data in both input and
output both well in both training and
input if I'm not mistaken so in other
words that's arguing so okay for the
case of numerical data we understand how
we're going to do that numerical data
the most obvious way to do that is to
have a raw missing sitting in there for
performance purpose we might want to
have we might want to have it be
different yeah back to Ray and then say
there's a meeting a briefing for all
right okay so so then the question is do
we want to have a what do we call it
some kind of missing data wrapper where
we have an object and we have something
that says
our missing hmm I mean did you propose
something like this yeah
does advantage of then we can the thing
yes now of course a question it's a
missing data is a weird word for this
you know cuz missing we already have the
thing missing which represents a piece
of missing data so what this is is an
indirect missingness thing I mean this
is more like missing annotation or
something yeah so we have a bunch of
things like we have weighted data we
have sensor data which are these kinds
of things
I'm saying they have no information
associated with them
you
okay then one question is what how do
you combine these things yeah that's a
good question okay so I don't
particularly like using the term missing
data for this thing here because it's
really not that suggests that this that
we are presenting is the missing data
whereas we're merely saying where the
data is missing see here weighted data
it's the data but it's got weights see
what I'm saying but I think it it's it
has the you know who is that masked man
type type um I don't know Masek data
just sounds like I don't know it's you
know password field that's my doesn't
doesn't give me the right emotional
feeling so to speak um let's see I mean
and is it the case that we always want I
[Music]
mean really
whether it's missing which is kind of an
emotive word whether it's merely being
ignored is sort of irrelevant to us
except as James has pointed out whether
it's used in the training cycle right
saying it
to have a name which doesn't have
missing units
what's that doesn't have missing which
is why masks data would be I mean it's
sort of ignored data or something but
that's not good either
it is morning and it might be like the
mark mark data missus I'm marked yeah
disregarded data this is the more
accurate term probably you see ignored
data suggests that this thing itself is
the ignored data yeah it's like missing
yeah
so what that would do is would contain
data as is and then some indicator of
where it's where it's sort of yeah
where's I mean the word ignoring might
be interesting it's a little weird to
say missing impute of something with
ignoring um I have a bad feeling we are
not going to wrap this up here I think
we're going to have to continue because
I'm really late for something else um
drat what do we think do you think we
are going to let's me see do you think
if we want to run for another 20 minutes
that we will be able to get somewhere
here I can push a different me at
another meeting to a different time or
do you think we should try and pull this
up another time Roger yeah I feel we're
slightly close but I'm worried that this
is really close to the sanitation
business which we are close to figuring
out but we have not figured it out right
because if we have the annotation stuff
then we've got a mechanism you know we
definitely don't want two different
mechanisms for this I think we can
assume
this is what you're building at CNN Amir
I think you can assume that your
functions will be given you know your
inter functions will be given just
locations where things are to be
disregarded and those locations may be
found by basically saying you know
position of something with some
particular value or they may be found by
being literally given those positions
yes I think it would be simple to use
something simple like that I do believe
it will be to solve this sort of
representation problem for big
contiguous data and to not sort of use
the missing rapper which is as we
already talked about this very costly
who will be useful for quantity arrays
and all kinds of other areas yes it
would be and they might they might in
fact use I think the dual purpose thing
that we talked about for annotations is
to have sort of both a rapper and an
option when there is an object yes will
be exceedingly useful I agree I think
things like Python numpy have got like
you know equivalent structures where you
have say mass data and take the mean of
that it'll ignore the things which are
masked out yeah which we which we have
versions of what may have four years but
but the problem is that there are two
cases here look
mental cases for annotation I mean this
is now you know it's annotation from
outside annotation annotation with of
you know annotated data elements or it's
annotation from outside are the two
cases and the annotation from outside
breaks into the case where there is
existing wrapper there's an existing
wrapper and there isn't an existing
wrapper and you are applying something
so it's probably what we probably want
to say is you know this probably wants
to be annotate blah blah blah that
returns a thing which is called and
notated or some such other thing um that
contains the information right that's
the that's the canonical form where you
could take well actually I'm sorry that
wouldn't I'm sorry I'm wrong about this
I'm wrong about this I'm wrong because
this is this is saying there is an
existing wrapper would be something like
image and then then as we said on the
right hand side there annotation rules
arrow whatever makes sense I do
should continue this in another
annotation being said I think that this
is not kind of concluding client we had
some suggestions from our livestream
here one of them is various people with
suggestions about filling fill missing
for the imputation stuff um or smart
fill data we have never used the word
smart anywhere in our system but I do
think that that concept of comparing
Auto filling is not a bad concept for
some I mean how do we feel about things
like it's not quite autofill but it's
and it's also not quite smart fill but
it's the concept of filling reports
about that I think that's what you say
filling in missing values yeah I think I
think that's a more mainstream
terminology than impute missing values
even if that's heavily used in a machine
learning community so fill missing was
another suggestion from the live stream
which is actually not bad it's better
honestly it's better than impute missing
yeah I prefer it as well what would be
the there should be a verb and under
sort of I don't know commit a noun
I think um okay so film is saying this
would be this will be the analog of data
impute yep similar functions the in
pewter function function not quite right
not quite right what is the let's see um
what's the other case that we need we
need one that is going to return self we
need to fill missing to a bunch of data
that is you know where it's self
fillings yes which I assume would fit me
seeing B and that's the one above then
you should change I'm not sure is that
really the the no so we find the data
and computation so it'll be more missing
feeling it's really weird
missing feel if we follow the same
pattern as we did before
missing feeling and missing feel emotion
person fell yeah it will be missing feel
missing feeling and missing feel a
function that would be what we do
normally France provides any function
alright until next time okay so we
should
we should plan to reconvene soon about
this for those on our live stream we
actually have another life stream
meeting coming up in about 20 minutes so
alright so we're gonna wrap this up and
certainly you can untangle hopefully
these these various I who is p.m. in the
annotation thing I know that response
I think that's weird I think that's I
think that made sense when it looked
like it was a annotating front-end
elements but I think you better take
that from him oh boy
oh he okay sounds good thanks to the
folks on the live stream great
suggestions and thank you to everybody
here see all soon